let's say that we have three integers a
b
and c and we know that all of these
integers are greater than zero so
they're integers and they are greater
than zero
and we also know that the expression
that the expression a
plus b
over c
that this is also an integer the entire
expression if you were to evaluate it is
also
an integer
and then finally we know that a
is
divisible
divisible or another way of saying it
that a is a multiple of c so a is
divisible
by c which is another way of saying is a
is a multiple
multiple
of c so this is what we know a b and c
are integers all greater than zero we
know that the expression a plus b over c
also an integer and that a is a multiple
of c or in other ways that c divides
perfectly into a
so our question for you or the question
for all of us to work out right now
is
is b
a
multiple does b have to be a multiple of
c let me write it that way
does
b
given all of these constraints does b
have to be
a multiple
multiple
of c
so let's see how we can i encourage you
to pause the video right now to kind of
come up with your own answer about
whether b has to be a multiple of c
so now that you've unpaused things let's
work it out so let's go to our original
expression right over here we have a
plus b over c and and really one way to
to
to tackle this is to really just play
around with this expression and see if
we can come up with any conclusions here
so one we could try to rewrite a plus b
over c we could rewrite that as a over c
plus b over c
a over c plus b over c and this
expression is the exact same thing as
our as our first expression so we know
that this entire thing is going to be an
integer
that old whole thing is going to be an
now what do we know about these parts
well a over c this is a divided by c
we know that a is divisible by c we know
that a is a multiple of c so a divided
by c this is going to be an integer so
let me write that
so
this information
this information right over here
tells us that this thing right over here
that a divided by c is going to be an
integer
this is going to be an integer
now if i have an integer and i add
something to it and the whole thing is
an integer well the thing that i'm
adding to it must be an integer the only
way that i get an integer plus something
to be an integer is if the thing i'm
adding it to is also an integer so this
so this there's no way that i could add
an integer to a non-integer and then get
an integer so this has to be
this has to be an integer has to
be an integer
and if b over c is an integer that means
that b that yes b must be a multiple of
c
so the answer here is
yes